this episode of real law review was made
possible by skill share learn to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking the link in the description
wrapper to Milly Alfonso Ribeiro aka
Carlton banks and the backpack kid are
soon the makers of fortnight the world's
most popular video game for stealing
their dance moves you cannot make this
up but can you copyright a dance in
today's real law review it's a dance off
[Music]
hey legal eagles welcome back to real
law review as always subscribe for more
cutting-edge analysis and stay until the
end when I give you my prediction for
who will win this ridiculous lawsuit but
let's start at the beginning can you
even copyright a dance well the answer
believe it or not is yes although dance
is an art form that is as old as time
itself copyright protection for dance
specifically choreography is a recent
development being able to copyright
dances is a relatively recent
development which was codified in 1976
when Congress changed the Copyright Act
to include choreography and pantomime to
the list of things that you had actually
copyright Congress defined choreography
as the composition and arrangement of a
related series of dance moves and
patterns in an organized coherent whole
so on the question of whether you can
actually copyright dances the answer is
sometimes yes and a dance is in question
here look very similar if I had to guess
it looks like the makers of Fortnight
basically copied to Millie's dance frame
for frame you can see here that the
dances are almost identical and that
goes for Alfonso Ribeiro 'he's carlton
dance as well you can see that it is
very very similar to the dance that you
can buy in the game fortnight and of
course backpack kids short dance move is
basically the same here as well and
there are other dances in fortnight that
you can buy as downloadable content that
also look very very similar to other
artists for example there is the Poisson
dance from scrubs that was created by
Donald Faison it's basically the same
move for move in the game itself so it
seems pretty clear here that the makers
of
tonight are trying to make a profit off
of the dances that were created by other
people but just because the dances are
almost identical does not mean that is
copyright infringement first a little
background on copyright law in general
how do you get copyright protection well
you have to have original expression
that is fixed into a tangible medium
here video counts as a tangible medium
so if you record a dance into video
that's actually one of the preferred
ways of copywriting a potential dance so
that's not really an issue but you
should know that copyright does not
apply to ideas themselves only the
actual expression and you can't
copyright functional things that's what
patent protection is for and courts have
interpreted the copyright Clause of the
Constitution as requiring minimal
creativity in addition to originality
originality is the bedrock principle of
copyright that requires that to qualify
for copyright protection a work must be
original to its author and that means
that that work must be independently
created by the author itself and it must
possess at least some minimal degree of
creativity so for example you can't
copyright a single note or a single word
but you can string a series of those
notes together
to make a copy writable song and you can
string together a series of
uncopyrightable words to form an
original book but there is absolutely no
bright-line rule that says it requires
this many words to form a copyrightable
phrase or a book or it requires this
many notes to be a copyrightable song
certainly there are very short songs and
very short literary works that despite
being very very small still qualify for
copyright expression so it is an open
question as to how many dance moves you
have to string together in order to form
a copy rideable dance choreography so
for the purposes of this discussion I'm
going to assume that these dances are
original to these authors who are filing
this lawsuit but it may very well not be
the case of course I am no expert in
dance
anyone who has ever seen me dance at a
wedding knows that that is absolutely
the case but to me these are the kinds
of dances that may very well be products
of popular culture and merely
popularized by the various center
ten years who were filing suit here
which would basically doom their
copyright claims that they weren't the
original author but for the purposes of
this video let's assume that they are
original for copyright purposes and I
will also note that there is footage of
Alfonso Ribeiro where he claims that he
stole his particular carlton dance from
courtney cox and combine that with some
dance moves sort of eddie murphy how did
it originate it was it just like one of
your dances that you did when you're
younger and you're like no I still look
Courtney Cox okay okay that combination
about the combo of all of that okay a
little bit of me awesome yeah now that
is certainly not the kind of statement
that I would want a client to make in
the context of a copyright suit but it
doesn't necessarily doom his claim
because again a song is always going to
be made up of non copyrightable notes to
form a melody so just because there are
constituent parts that might not be
copyrightable sometimes and there's a
big caveat there sometimes when you add
those things together you can create an
individual work that is original on its
own or sometimes they qualify as a
compilation but that being said it's not
a great statement it just doesn't
necessarily doom his case now before I
dig into the actual lawsuits that have
been filed and the dance moves at issue
here that's one last thing I need to
tell you as it regards copyright of
dances and choreography which is that
when the House passed the 1976 Copyright
Act it issued a report along with the
act itself to clarify some of the
changes that it made and in that house
report Congress specified that
choreographic works do not include
social dance steps and simple routines
thus for example Congress exempted
things like the basic waltz step the
hustle step the second position of
classical ballet all of those things are
not copyrightable but Congress also
specified that this is not a restriction
against the incorporation of social
dance steps and symbol routines into an
otherwise larger choreographic work the
Second Circuit which is one step below
the Supreme Court in the Horgan versus
Macmillan case how
that social dance steps folk dance steps
and individual valet steps may be
utilized as the choreographers basic
material much in the same way that words
are the writers basic material so at
issue here are several lawsuits that
were filed by the rapper to Milly
alfonso ribeiro and backpack kid they
all seem to be represented by the same
law firm and they're all filing suit in
the federal court in Los Angeles the
Central District of California where
I've practiced many many times and in
those lawsuits the performers are
alleging that the makers of fortnight
and a number of other video game
developers have basically stolen all of
the different dances to include them in
downloadable content from which they
make a profit and that that qualifies as
copyright infringement they are fairly
bare-bones complaints but they do seem
to state the essential elements for
copyright infringement so given that the
dances in question here are basically
identical the main legal issue is
whether the dances are social dances or
whether they are choreographic works in
other words are these dances
copyrightable in the first place now
normally I would just look up the case
law and look for cases that have
interpreted the phrase social dances in
the Copyright Act and compare them to
cases that have interpreted
choreographic works and give you an easy
answer as to whether the dances in
question qualify as social dances or not
unfortunately there are very very few
cases that have dealt with this language
again this is a very new aspect of the
copyright law in general and really very
few people have even litigated this
there's basically one case on point and
that again comes out of the Central
District of California which is where a
lot of copyright law originates because
that's where Hollywood is basically the
only court case to deal with this
language is the court case of Bikram
yoga versus evolution yoga which dealt
with a sequence of 26 yoga poses and the
issue there was whether the yoga poses
would qualify as a copyright of a work a
choreographic work or whether they were
non copyrightable in the first place the
court sided with the defendants stating
that the 26 yoga poses quote hardly
seems to fall within the definition of
pantomime or choreographic work because
of the simplicity of the sequence and
the fact that it is not a dramatic
formitz however the plaintiff appealed
to the Ninth Circuit and while the Ninth
Circuit agreed that the defendants
should win they did not agree on the
basis for that decision and the Ninth
Circuit held that the sequence of yoga
moves was not copyrightable not because
it wasn't a choreographic work but
because it was a demonstration of an
idea process or system to which
copyright protection may in no case
extend so given that this is a matter of
first impression where the courts really
haven't weighed in on what constitutes
copyright infringement in the context of
a dance or a choreography who's going to
win these lawsuits well let's think like
a lawyer so here's what I think both
sides are going to argue first the
plaintiffs are going to argue that these
dances are very very unique they're
instantly recognizable if you see
someone performing the Carlton dance you
know that that is the Carlton dance that
appeared on The Fresh Prince of bel-air
and the fact that they are so unique and
so recognizable shows that they should
get copyright protection despite the
fact that they are very very short and
just in the same way that you can string
together uncopyrightable notes to form a
copyrightable song you can string
together uncopyrightable moves movement
in the air to form a copyrightable dance
and it would be weird to make dance less
copyrightable than its counterparts in
the literary or musical world I think
that the defendants would counter by
saying that these are not minimally
creative or unique these are just
standard dance moves that you'll see
anywhere like a scene affair or a trope
that they're just putting together what
people have been doing for a very very
long time and most important I think the
defendants would argue that the dance is
in question are social dances and
therefore not copyrightable they are far
more akin to the foxtrot
or the waltz than they are to an entire
hour-long ballet a work of choreography
that was intended to receive copyright
protection in my own personal view as
someone who has litigated many many
copyright issues I think the defendants
have the better argument here to me if
the phrase social dance the exception to
the copyright clause is meant to have
any meaning whatsoever I think it's
meant to include the dances at
issue here I think that Congress
intended to create a differentiation
between large choreographed work and
just a social dance like the waltz
maybe the Macarena would qualify as well
and I think these short dances would
qualify as social dances that were meant
to be performed in public as opposed to
being a copyrighted work after all we
don't want copyright law to allow
artists to sue anyone performing their
dance moves in public
wherever the young people are performing
their dance moves clubs sock hops I
don't know wherever you people hang out
so this is untested and could go either
way but I think that the defendants are
likely to win as a matter of law but
because this is a matter of first
impression the courts really haven't
weighed in on this and there are
reasonable arguments on either side the
courts could go either way the law is
constantly evolving and I'll be
fascinated to see how this one turns out
and if you want to create your own
copyrightable choreography first you
need to learn how to dance I would
recommend mi rhoi Barnardo's Skillshare
classes on basic hip-hop dancing where
you'll learn the basics of modern dance
and how to dance to people like Justin
Timberlake and Drake to artists who have
never sued your favorite game developer
Skillshare is an online learning
community that has over 20,000 classes
on everything like lifestyle design and
technology the first 500 legal eagles to
click on the link below will get to
three months of Skillshare the free
premium membership gives you unlimited
access to must know topics so you can
improve your skills and learn new things
like learning how to dance better than I
can so click the link get to three
months of skill share and start learning
today so until next time I'll see you in
court